it's 2008 and I'm just finishing my
first year of Design School and I'm at
my first year end review which is a form
of ritual torture for design students
where they make you take everything you
made over the course of the year and lay
it out on a table and stand next to it
while a bunch of professors most of whom
you've never seen before give you their
unfiltered opinions of it so it's my
turn and I'm standing next to my table
everything neatly lined up and I'm just
hoping that my professors can see how
much effort I've put into making my
designs practical and ergonomic and
sustainable and I'm starting to get
really nervous because for a long time
no one says anything it's just
completely silent and then one of the
professors starts to speak and he says
your work gives me a feeling of joy joy
I wanted to be a designer because I want
to solve real problems joy is nice I
guess
but it's kind of light not substantial
but I was also kind of intrigued because
joy is this intangible feeling and how
does that come from the stuff on the
table next to me I asked the professors
how do things make us feel joy
how do tangible things make us feel
intangible joy they hand and hot and
gestured a lot with their hands they
just do they said I packed up my things
for the summer but I couldn't stop
thinking about this question and this
launched a journey one that I didn't
know at the time would take me 10 years
to understand the relationship between
the physical world and the mysterious
quixotic
emotion we call joy and what I
discovered
but not only are they linked but that
the physical world can be a powerful
resource to us and creating happier
healthier lives after my review I
thought I know what joy feels like but
what is it exactly and I found that even
scientists don't always agree and they
sometimes use the words joy and
happiness and positivity more or less
interchangeably but broadly speaking
when psychologists use the word joy what
they mean is an intense momentary
experience of positive emotion one that
makes us smile and laugh and feel like
we want to jump up and down and this is
actually a technical thing that feeling
of wanting to jump up and down is one of
the ways that scientists measure joy
it's different than happiness which
measures how good we feel over time joy
is about feeling good in the moment
right now and this was interesting to me
because as a culture we are obsessed
with the pursuit of happiness and yet in
the process we kind of overlook joy so
this got me thinking
where does joy come from I started
asking everyone I knew and even people I
just met on the street about the things
that brought them joy on the subway in a
cafe on an airplane it was hi nice to
meet you what brings you joy I felt like
a detective I was like when did you last
see it who are you with what color was
it didn't anyone else see it I was the
Nancy Drew of joy and after a few months
of this I noticed that there were
certain things that started to come up
again and again and again they were
things like cherry blossoms and bubbles
swimming pools and tree houses hot air
balloons and googly eyes
and ice cream cones especially the ones
with the sprinkles these things seem to
cut across lines of age and gender and
ethnicity I mean if you think about it
we all stop and turn our heads to the
sky when a multicolored arc of a rainbow
streaks across it and fireworks we don't
even need to know what they're for
and we feel like we're celebrating -
these things aren't joyful for just a
few people
they're joyful for nearly everyone
they're universally joyful and seeing
them all together it gave me this
indescribably hopeful feeling the
sharply divided politically polarized
world we live in sometimes has the
effect of making our differences feel so
vast as to be insurmountable and yet
underneath it all there's a part of each
of us that finds joy in the same things
and though we're often told that these
are just passing pleasures in fact
they're really important because they
remind us of the shared humanity we find
in our common experience of the physical
world but I still needed to know what is
it about these things that makes them so
joyful I had pictures of them up on my
studio wall and every day I would come
in and try to make sense of it and then
one day something just clicked I saw all
these patterns round things pops of
bright color symmetrical shapes a sense
of abundance and multiplicity a feeling
of lightness or elevation when I saw it
this way I realized that the the feeling
of joy is mysterious and elusive we can
access it through tangible physical
attributes or what designers call
aesthetics a word that comes from the
same root as the Greek word ice animai
which means I feel I sense I perceive
and since these patterns were telling me
that joy begins with the census I began
calling them aesthetics of joy the
sensations of joy and in the wake of
this discovery I noticed something but
as I walked around I began spotting
little moments of joy everywhere I went
a vintage yellow car or a clever piece
of street art it was like I had a pair
of rose-colored glasses and now that I
knew what to look for I was seeing it
everywhere it was like these little
moments of joy were hidden in plain
sight and at the same time I had another
realization that if these are the things
that bring us joy then why did so much
of the world look like this why do we go
to work here why do we send our kids to
schools that look like this why do our
cities look like this and this is most
acute for the places that house the
people that are most vulnerable among us
nursing homes hospitals homeless
shelters housing projects how did we end
up in a world that looks like this we
all start out joyful but as we get older
being colorful or exuberant opens us up
to judgment adults who exhibit genuine
joy are often dismissed as childish or
too feminine or unserious or
self-indulgent and so we hold ourselves
back from joy and we end up in a world
that looks like this but if the
aesthetics of joy can be used to help us
find more joy in the world around us
then couldn't they also be used to
create more joy I spent the last two
years scouring my planet looking for
different ways that people have answered
this question and this led me to the
work of the artist Arakawa and the poet
Madeleine Ganz who believed that these
kinds of environments are
literally killing us and so they set out
to create an apartment building that
they believed would reverse aging and
this is it it's a real place just
outside Tokyo I spent a night there and
it's a lot the floor is undulate so you
don't end up walking around so much is
kind of bouncing around the apartment
and there are bright colors in every
direction I'm not sure I left any
younger
but it says if by trying to create an
apartment that would make us feel
youthful they ended up creating one that
was joyful and yes this is a bit much
for everyday life but it made me wonder
what about the rest of us how do we
bring these ideas back into the real
world so I started finding people who
are doing just that for example this
hospital designed by the Danish artist
fool Sharon or these schools transform
by the nonprofit public colour what's
interesting is that public colour has
heard from school administrators who say
that attendance improves graffiti
disappears and kids actually say they
feel safer in these painted schools and
this aligns with research conducted in
four countries which shows that people
working in more colourful offices are
actually more alert more confident and
friendlier than those working in drab
spaces why would this be the case well
as I started to trace back our love of
color I found that some researchers see
a connection to our evolution colour in
a very primal way as a sign of life a
sign of energy and the same is true of
abundance we evolved in a world where
scarcity is dangerous and abundance
meant survival so one
fedo which happens to be the singular of
confetti in case you were wondering
isn't very joyful but multiply it and
you have a handful of one of the most
joyful substances on the planet the
architect Emmanuelle Moreau uses this
idea in her work a lot this is a nursing
home she designed where she uses these
multicolored spheres to create a feeling
of abundance and what about all those
round things I noticed well it turns out
neuroscientists have studied this too
they put people into fMRI machines and
they showed them pictures of angular
objects and round ones and what they
found is that the amygdala part of the
brain and associated part with fear and
anxiety lit up when people looked at
angular objects but not when they looked
at the round ones they speculate that
because angles in nature are often
associated with objects that may be
dangerous to us that we evolved an
unconscious sense of caution around
these shapes
whereas curves set us at ease you can
see this in action in the new Sandy Hook
elementary school after the mass
shooting there in 2012 the architects
Wiggles close partners knew that they
needed to create a building that was
secure but they wanted to create one
that was joyful and so they filled it
with curves there are waves running
along the side of the building and these
squiggly canopies over the entryway and
the whole building bends toward the
entrance in a welcoming gesture each
moment of joy is small but over time
they head up to more than the sum of
their parts and so maybe instead of
chasing after happiness what we should
be doing is embracing joy and finding
ways to put ourselves in the path of it
more often deep within us we all have
this impulse to seek out joy in our
surroundings and we have it for a reason
joy isn't some superfluous extra it's
directly connect
to our fundamental instinct for survival
on the most basic level the drive toward
joy is the drive toward life thank you
[Applause]